I hope you guys are ready to augment
because this week we're getting Deus Ex
it's a new week and it's time for new
releases this week you're going to the
not-too-distant year 20-29 where the
mechanically augmented have been pushed
to the point of anger this is taking
place two years after the events of
human Revolution you remember that aughh
incident where all the mechanically
altered humans were uncontrollable and
violent will those jerks the Illuminati
were behind that trying to divide the
world with fear with tensions at an
all-time high Adam Jensen sticks to the
plan of going after those jerk
Illuminati and trying to keep the peace
between two groups at war if you
preorder deus ex mankind divided
preloading begins on august twenty-first
the release date is two days later enjoy
but there's so much more this week with
SNK releasing the king of fighters 14
for ps4 as you can see the visual style
is 3d models like Maxim impact but it's
on a 2d plane like Street Fighter 4
you're losing hyperdrive system in
exchange for max mode where you can
perform unlimited x special moves for a
brief period of time and that time
changes based on the players position
there's 50 fighters 31 returning and
that means 19 new if you do the math and
you can take your pick of those in party
battle mode that allows six players in 3
on 3 vs battles you get your fight on on
the twenty-third madden NFL 17 is out
this week for fans of the popular sports
franchise madden 17 has developed new
ground game mechanics that provide
players with the ability to experience
more balanced offensive game play
allowing them to be a bit more creative
when carrying the ball in addition to
this there's some new defensive AI
putting your teammates into positions to
stop the run or pass game features such
as ultimate team and franchise mode will
make a return you probably remember that
voters picked the madden NFL 16 cover to
New York Giants wide receiver Odell
Beckham jr. and that gave rob gronkowski
the second place trophy and no cover
well they fixed that this year putting
new england patriots tight
on this year's cover you can grab this
off shelves on the twenty-third this was
a surprise to me but there's a pretty
interesting first-person exploration
game that might be up your alley it's
valley a game where you're uncovering
the mysteries of yeah valley you'll be
exploring this vast and beautiful
landscape in your leaf suit something
that seems to give you some pretty
fantastical powers you can give life to
dying trees and animals leaping the
distance of a giant football field and
swinging from tree to tree like Georgia
the jungle we're just not exactly sure
why you're doing all these cool things
it appears to be just another aspect of
valleys mystery and you get to uncover
those mysteries on the 24th metric 0
plus is coming out on consoles and PC
you might remember this strange
interactive graph puzzler from Vita but
this is an all new experience with new
challenges there's an entirely new story
in this game the music's been revised
and most importantly metric 0 plus
contains over 40 new puzzles utilizing
new gameplay mechanics considering how
this was originally on the Vita they
actually had to come up with brand new
mechanics so that it would work on
console and PC so if you were ever
interested in this metric puzzler
there's never been a better opportunity
to give metric 0 plus a try so those are
all the games we think you should know
about this week which ones are you going
to get remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and sometimes
they change I'll see you guys again next
week
you